okay I've been given the signal to start
so so what I'm going to talk to you
today is about different ways of
controlling what users can access both
inside of a web application asp.net core
and also in the database but this really
came from a some work I did for a client
they they came to me because they had
lots of databases and lots of
performance and lots of things they
wanted to do and I've written this book
and a framework core in action
and so we had a really nice discussion
about that and I felt very happy with
those bits and then they said we have
this quite complex set of rules on what
our users do and she's where we went
down a hole right so so I said we were
talking through what they need you to do
and this is really important to them so
I said well and what if what have you
done so far and I said oh we had two
developers working on it for about a
month and a half two months but we fired
them because I couldn't do it
so so that was a start and then okay so
did they do anything I could look at no
there's no code you got to start again
and okay so what who's what other
developers he got ok well um it's you
and a guy in the company that learn
angularjs in his spare time is gonna do
the front-end they did have a good
project manager and they were gonna hire
people but it was a you know on the
first talking about databases that was
very happy but now I'm not so confident
so this is a story about how I solved
this
and some of the good things that came
out of it and what I said to them that I
can help you on on the database I'll
give me three or four weeks and I'll
look into this problem and see whether I
feel I can solve it or not so we're
gonna talk about that and some of the
things that you might find useful out of
it but first we're gonna do a super
quick look at asp.net core identity
because this is you'll get the
terminologies right and you know make
sure everybody's on the same page so
this identity feature has two parts
authentication which is logging in
I've lost my password all those sort of
things and then authorization which is
once you're logged in what can you do
okay and those two parts are gonna turn
up a lot the other thing is it in in
authentication with asp.net core you can
use their own system which is really
good and but you can use lots of other
things social logins and you have api's
to allow external authentication people
take over that part when it comes to
authorization what people can do there
are two ways you can do it in asp.net
core one is the role-based so each user
is given a set of roles and this
authorize that you can see they're
authorized roles staff manager will you
put that on a on a action inside the
website and you the user will only be
able to access it if they've got the
role startled or manager and new in
asp.net core is policy based where you
could write your own own rules and they
had an example around
checking with their a each and things
like that I didn't quite get that at the
beginning but it turns out policy based
rules authorization is very helpful so
so that's the super quick intro I want
to talk about the limitations of role
based systems role based systems have
been around for a while it was in
asp.net MVC and I used it and I'm sure
you've used it and here are my issues
the with a big application you end up
with quite complicated role lists and
they spread all over all over the place
and they're really hard to manage all
right
there is another thing which okay if you
want to change a role take that exam
example at the top say I wanted to have
a role director added to that thing so
I'd have to edit the code go comma
director in the roles so you've got to
redeploy your system to get that out in
in the wild and that's okay now because
we're used to deploying a lot but
philosophically it feels wrong it feels
like a use an admin person should be
sitting at a table and and changing the
way your system works and this is a
personal one but I hate strings because
I'm Dyslexic because so business manager
could turn to bismillah and I wouldn't
notice it so this is the personal thing
but so I really love intellisense
anything that's going to kind of sort it
out for me you may wonder how I wrote a
500 page book with dyslexia but you've
got good spell checkers and in tennis
no he didn't over to code okay so let's
go back to the to the client and I'll
list you some of the things that they
needed that the current out the box
system wouldn't do the first one was
this is retail and people work in lots
of different places they don't love you
know they're working one shop as a
manager for the week and then their work
in the weekend as just a sales assistant
and they'll move around and this and
this company had been running for many
years and people use they email to log
in so you could have someone who would
use their email but they may work in
multiple places that real look really
won't work with asp.net core because
everything is joint you know glued
together once you log in with an email
you get this so I had to break that
apart the other thing you're talking to
you customer and you get these
interesting things that they say obvious
um major customer runs their system very
differently to other people and what a
manager does for in in there is a very
stiffen set of capabilities to what the
other people do and after adjust to that
so that tells me that the role manager
changes depending on what the company is
this is a multi-tenant system so they've
got you know company a and all its
retail outlets and Company B and there
will be it could be different and you
can't do that with asp.net core out of
the box and the other thing like most
services like this you can buy the base
system and then you have add-ons that
you pay for so they want to filter that
out and I wanted to make that part of
the authorized
I'm not gonna I'm gonna spend a little
bit at a time at the end looking at the
database not very long because I think
it's on the bit that people find useful
is this authorization in the web app but
this was heavily multi-tenant if you
don't know the term it's just exactly
what I said you've got one database and
you've got multiple separate tenants or
in this case I'm calling them companies
and you have to keep the data completely
separate you know security nightmare
there you need to make that very
different and this system had divisions
upon division so that you know you had a
company that carries was across the
whole of the US that a West Coast
division and central in a East Division
and the West Cota got a la it cetera and
we'll see that at the end how do we do
that
so where do you start well I'm a
independent contractor I don't work with
other people but you need techie friends
all right so I talked to Jerry pedlar
who's become a friend sheriff out on his
weekly newsletter that is a very good
newsletter and he put me on to Dominick
Bayer and policy server and that was
useful and I looked at that and I was
under I'm on a time constraint so I sent
the email off to than saying you know
cuz they sold it so you know oh what
could you do and I got out of office
saying oh I'm traveling so had to get on
couldn't wait for that and I'm glad I
did because when they came back it
wasn't totally clear that it would do
what we needed and for a multi-tenant
version it's $25,000 and I can tell you
what we built was a lot less than that
but it was very helpful it was very
helpful and the thing that they did was
they split authentication from
authorization and once you once you've
heard that and once you've thought about
that it's obvious but it wasn't obvious
until I read their stuff so thank you to
them and the idea is you get someone
logs in and you get a user ID right and
then you use that with other information
to decide what the user can do so that
that was really useful
I also philosophical idea but roles I
think work well for humans but for the
so you know you sell system manager you
can imagine that you have these roles
and they kind of fit people but when it
comes to the web application you're
really using use cases so can process
sale there's most likely you know four
or five Web API is that you hit to do
that so that's that's a use case and I
called those permissions and I split
those those apart it turns out that
policy based authentication is really
helpful if you want to do something
different this is the way you do it
because you can set your own rules and
finally I I used enums for my
permissions because if I get
intellisense but it turned out that and
that's why I chose it but it turned out
to be a really good decision and I'll
you'll see why so when I finished with
the client and I felt there was some
really I'd found some really useful
things so I wrote some other way with it
my class permission and and it helped
them because I wrote in the second art
cause some of the things they need you
to do later and it you can go to it now
if you want but it's it shot up my my on
my tech blog and it's now number one
taking about 5,000 pages a month and
there was lots and lots of comments and
more worryingly people would i'd had a
built a simple application that people
could run again so that I knew that code
was right that I was putting in the
article but people were now trying to
take this slightly crappy application
and use it in their situation so I'm
currently in the process of building a
much better version and updating things
and you're seeing some of this in this
talk so let me take you through what
happens this gives you an overview of
what I'm gonna do and then I'll show you
the bits inside so someone logs in I
don't care how but I want a user ID and
then I have something which it's a very
simple you know user to user to role so
it's just a very simple look up and it
says oh this user ID has these roles and
it I've said it's sales and first day
just to make it interesting and then I
turn those into permissions so we
started with roles but we don't need
those when we're going to the actual
application we're going to use these
permissions and you can see here has got
I've got three sales has got three
permissions and the first aid has call
ambulance and then what I need to do is
I need to get those permissions into
what's called the users claims so when
someone
is logged into asp.net core there they
have some claims which go around and
they're stored in a cookie or a token
and but they are what will determine
what who that user is when they come to
the side so I need to get these
permissions and you'll notice that the
permissions are shown as numbers rather
the names because it makes them smaller
and that's useful because if you use
cookies is the limit so that was very
useful so that's so this authentications
setup stage now is something that I've
written I've used asp.net core at the
login stage but I've written that and
then per HTT HTTP request these claims
get put into the system and I can use
the policy based approach to check that
they've got the permission so in this
case Joe wants to go to an in action
result bottom right no yep right and yes
he has the permission read stock so he
can access it okay so that's that's the
overview let's go and see some parts in
it so oh yes no before I go on once you
split this you start to see something
you see that the scary bit is the
authentication part it's the bit that I
think we all worry about is like have I
hashed the passwords right have I you
know should I have the is this cookie
it's secured enough so that's a scary
part and if you separate that off and
you realize that the rest is not scary
right all of this you can unit test all
the rest of the stuff and I have unit
tests that goes and looks
all the actions in all the controllers
and make sure it's got the right it's
either got to have an actuary called
allowing anonymous or you've just have
the authorized one which means you just
logged in or it has to have has
permission which is my attribute and so
you can check everything and and if I
feel very comfortable with that it's
just the front end and in discussions
with my client I'd done something with
asp.net cause own system but in the end
they just felt a little bit worried and
so we we use an external authentication
system called or zero and that meant
that someone else was worrying about all
that scary stuff all right
it made it a little bit harder to set up
users because you have to use a web api
that talks to or Siro and all that sort
of stuff but it was it was you've taken
that away and my client could say oh you
know if the passwords have been hacked
or something it's not me right
so that's good okay so um let's go and
look at the permissions as I said I used
a thumbs and it turns out to be a really
good idea because you can put attributes
on enums and you're gonna have hundreds
of ease all right so I can put on the
display attribute and I can give it in a
group name a name a description all
sorts of stuff so that's some poor admin
person that's got set up all these rules
can look at it and you'll see that in a
minute and the you you can decide how
finer detail you want I've in this the
product read I've got a separate one for
the read the create the update and the
so you can go very fine if you want but
for the rolls I've got one that says you
can see the rolls and another one that
says you can change the rolls you can
add them update them or delete them so
it's up to you how fine and details you
want to go see the obsolete at the
bottom that's nice too because you do
not want to reuse numbers if you've now
not using that permission you don't want
to use it there's lots of scary stories
about reusing numbers and having chaos
so you market with an obsolete that
means that in the code you'll get
warning if you're using it and also in
my listing anything it's got obsolete it
won't show it okay so that that was
really good and in my little demo
application you see you can list it all
and you've got the descriptions you
could imagine you can filter it down to
the the user admin and pick out the
things it makes it much easier for the
user so that's the permissions now we've
got how do we get them into the claims
oh yeah quick look at a class done with
NC framework or and this is just showing
you that I can the permissions look at
the bottom line permissions in rolls I
can pack those up and store them as a
string in the database and then I can
unpack them when someone reads them and
so that makes it it's not so important
in the database but it is for the cookie
but it also it means that from the
anybody using this class you're only
using enums but inside some magics going
on and I use third line down at the top
I in EF core you can have private fields
are map
to the database and that's what I do
there and the pack and unpack pack just
takes the number which is a 16-bit and
makes it into a Unicode char so it's
very efficient so let's now look at how
we get these permissions into the claims
so if you log in just standard login you
will get a claim called name which is
normally your email you'll get a user ID
which by default is a string containing
a grid and you get another security
thing that asp.net call uses itself I
want to add the permission so how do I
do that well I found this this really
nice thing called user claims principle
Factory and what you can do is every
time that someone logs in you can
capture by putting this in it will
instead of just putting the claims in it
will come to you and then you can add
your own claim so here is the code thank
you to Corazon see the link at the
bottom that's where I found it thank you
very much and you can see the generate
claims async which I override you get
the the claims that it would normally
have from the base then I have this
method called calc allowed permissions
which does that and then adds it as a
claim okay so that's that's a really
simple way to add anything to the claims
that you need going forward right and
that will happen once when you log in
I'm now going to show you a much more
complicated system I had to use this for
various reasons for my client but when I
first put the article out people say ah
but what happens if the if the
permissions and that all the roles for a
user I changed and they're already login
it won't it won't change until the
person logs out and back in again so yep
that's that's valid we we had discussed
that with the client and we were happy
it didn't really matter for them but in
the new version I've solved this so
there is an event that happens every
HTTP request and for if you are using
cookies it's called on validate
principle and you can get into this and
do things and you'll see that and so
what I do is I put something in there
that can recalculate things
this is runs in every HTTP request that
you don't want to spend looking at the
database every time do you you really
don't
so you have to be a bit more clever and
here is it's a bit complicated but I'll
explain so what I want to do is if I can
I want to get out straight away so I use
tix I had the store the time when the
users permissions were calculated and
that I compare that with it something
that is cached so that's so so when that
something is updated the cache changes
and I've got this lovely I like long
names given tix is higher than cache
ticks right and if that if that's true
that's fine there's not no problem and
it will return quickly but if it isn't I
haven't put that seethen line now
calculate the permission claim value and
last updated tix I haven't put the code
in there just for two it's similar to
that what you saw in the last
version the simple version but once
you've done that this bit at the bottom
is really nice of what you can do is you
can create a new claims principle and
you can see that the lot line third line
from the bottom replaced principal so
what I've done is I've recalculated
everything and updated all the
permissions in the claim and the last
line should renew equals true is very
important because that will tell the
cookie to update so that it it won't do
it next time so it's gonna be if you
change something it's going to take time
but after that it's gonna be quick
that's what you want oh yes if you used
um I I looked at Oh was open web
application security to look at but what
you know sure I use a cookie or should I
use a token and all that sort of stuff
and it's very deep in there but I
thought you get you get a thing which
tells you all the problems you have with
tokens and all the problems with goodies
and then you have to go through it and
work out what when it turned what you
can do and I decided that it said that a
token on its own was not enough you had
to have something else and the cookies
had some problems but asp.net pretty
much knows all those and has things to
deal with them right this is my opinion
but we went with with cookies for that
reason but if you want to look at tokens
look at blinking caret at the bottom
it's a really good site detailed stuff
and he's got lots on web api's with
tokens so if that's your bag then have a
look at that so um I'm going to show you
a complicated piece of code but don't
worry about it so what I've done
in the I have a what's called a
dbcontext which is handling all of my
authorization stuff and I I override to
save changes save changes with the bull
and save changes
a sync with a ball and I put this code
in there and it's complicated but what
is looking for as has anybody changed
things which will affect the user's
permissions and if it if it has it sets
that to true does the save and then
update this cache so that the next time
that it comes around that cache will be
higher than what the ticks in the tote
in the cookie and it will have to
recreate so that that works the only
thing I would say is caching across
multiple web applications is not trivial
getting that right and secure
well not secure but reliable is
difficult so you got to decide right do
you want if you want this thing which
will update as soon as you change
something fine implement that but if you
can get away with the simple one do that
because it's going to be much easier to
maintain okay
we're nearly there on putting this all
together so I've got to the pay the
point where I've got the policy stuff
and what what I've got is I've got Joe
he's got his permissions claim and I
have some I have some I add a policy
which will check that and you see I have
this attribute that this attribute
called has permission
bottom middle and so it's going to check
that Joe has got that here the the
policy based permissions that policy
based authorization is a bit complex and
I'm just showing you like the core bit
it's got all bits around it that a bit
fiddly but you can see here it comes in
with the context so I can get the claims
if it has if the user hasn't got these
pack permissions then there's no way
it's going to pass but then it comes
down to this and I've highlighted this
method of mine called this permission is
allowed it's an extension which takes
the permissions unpacks
amp assam and checks in those
permissions that it's got their
permission a name that is being applied
and that and that does it if you want to
look at policy based rules and doing
dynamic authorization then Gerry peso
has got a very good set of articles on
that it's I mean my code is full of
thanks to or see other people are we're
all building on each other which is
great in it so I write articles and I
I've read articles and that's how we're
going to get forward so we've come to
the end of that part and there's the
same diagram again and you can see I've
been through all of those steps and
you've seen the code about the only
thing you haven't seen is the is the
find user roles which is very simple
it's a user ID role name user ID rope
name okay so let's have
have a look at database I have written
the book so you've got to have a look at
the database and this is if you don't do
any filtering then you unless your code
manually does it you're going to get
everything so that's the thing on the
left all or nothing protection so you're
just going to get all that data and it's
up to you and what you do with it but if
we put a purl row protection in we can
we can lock that down and make that
better and EF core is great for this is
just great
lovely the example I have is the and
this comes from my second article is I'm
gonna give you a blow-by-blow of
personal data using the user ID as a key
right and I'm gonna show you how I do
that
and once you've seen that you'll there's
loads of other things you can do but
this is gives you the the base stuff so
in this case I've got some user
addresses and you can only address get
to the address or addresses that have
got your key in it so how do you do this
that you feel very sure that it's gonna
work right you could put it in your code
forget you could could forget so let's
see how we do it so I'm down in the I've
got a DB car I've got insights in F core
you have a context which a class which
is which inherits DB context and it
holds all the information about the
links to your database and all the
configuration about your database right
and that's that's what we've got here
and I've strips and things off so that I
can get it on this
Paige so the first thing you need to do
you need to get the user ID in which is
very easy because you you are going to
use dependency injection and I've got
this thing I get claims provider and
we'll see that later so all you need to
know is that I've got this user ID
inside the dbcontext the other thing I
do is I override Save Changes you've
seen this before I've shown just one of
them but what I'm doing is every time
you add something which has got the I
owned by interface which is this is the
thing that's gonna do it it's going to
put the user ID in that is going to call
that method called set owned by which is
in that interface and it's going to put
that user ID in that field and there's
no way around that
right it's gonna happen so therefore
that is going to be marked automatically
right and if you use Save Changes or if
you use AF call that's going to happen
and then the magic bit is that came in
with EF core is this query filter you
can put query filters on your classes
and it will filter out automatically
deeps are in inside the DB context
before it comes to you so if you do any
query if you do any fine and I found
that even if you use is it to secret and
a from sequel if you use that it adds a
bit of sequel on the end doesn't always
work but it it's going to lock it down
so you you can get round it by putting
in the method ignore query filter right
but it's pretty obvious what you've done
right so by default it will filter that
so I like this because it's
it's it's gonna happen it can't be
easily bypassed and again I have some
unit tests just to make sure that I've
put query filters on the the appropriate
classes and that yeah the only other
thing you need is a way to get the user
ID in and there is a this is my I could
get claims provider and there's a useful
thing called ihdt kong context accessor
and you can get the claims it might be
now so yeah so you have to handle that
but it will get the claims and pull that
out on every HTTP request that you where
you call that and then that and that's
it
that's that's a really secure way to
keep your data segregated I'm gonna show
you what I had to do for the client for
this multi-tenant thing it's you won't
need this but it will show you some of
the things that you might find useful oh
no it shows you what you could do and I
don't think you will need to do it but
it there's so many things get o get
opened up so I've got I've got two
tenants made up for you Inc which has
got a dress for you and a shirt for you
and a tie for you and I have Joe is the
LA district manager right so he wants to
just see the the data around there and
also I want to keep these these two for
ring and this pets too limited in the UK
I want to keep them separate so what I
did is I built a a data key using that
follows the hierarchy and I use the
primary key
to build it so when you come down here
the the the company up here is has got
one then it goes to the west coast we
want to then it goes down to LA which is
one to five etc so by giving the Joe
there the code one to five he cans and
then I had this Square query string
where it so starts with you can just see
that little bit of the data and so that
that again is is more than you most
likely need but it's a useful example of
what you can do so yeah that's just
looking at the same sort of things count
the in this case you have to link the
user to you have to link the user to
this as L a subgroup entity because
someone might come along and change the
the layout and change the hierarchy so
he needs to be able to link to that and
get the latest and this is a case where
if you're going to change the hierarchy
it's gonna be you you're going to have
to look at the same thing that I showed
you where it will update the the data
key so let's we nearly really there this
is a look at what I did for the client
with extra orange boxes that added
things that I haven't put in the the
thing that I've made open source and
written the articles about because I
don't think people need this but you can
see here that the login is more
complicated because Joe could work in
two different places and
yes if that's true yes it click which
one and you'll have a different ID
passed on so I use a local user ID then
and the other thing is when you're
finding a role it might be there'll be a
role manager with a tenant idea at zero
means every can every body can use that
for default but if it finds a manager
with the with the ID of the company like
this one two three four so you down
there
the roles there then it would override
that and so you could have a role which
is different for these for the people
for each company if you need it
and again the removing the paid for
permissions is very simple all it does
is it it knows which permissions are in
a module and if you haven't got that
module it'll strip it out so in this
case it strips out sell online because
they haven't bought that feature so yeah
that's so last thing is just to look at
the application that I actually built
for the client and what we ended up with
we ended up with two asp.net web apps
running with Weber api's one was doing
handle or all the admin and mainly the
login and then it passed it passed most
of the information went into the cookies
about where the person was and what they
could do there was if you had added a
new company
some stuff that went needed to go on
there and you can see there's a link
from the brown master into the blue web
application that was a another web
application which did all the grunt work
but it did all the stock control selling
etc etc and there they had we had a
multi-tenant database for that and with
an angular on the top and yeah so it was
it works they've got the ability to
extend it if they want in different ways
and Julian would be happy with this it's
all this is all using domain driven
design all the entities are and the I'm
using what's called packaged by feature
or what Jimmy Bogart calls vertical
slicing so I've tried to make the each
part of the system say what's on their
authentication and authorization that is
very is it is in one kind of set so that
if you wanted to move it somewhere it's
much easier to move it around and use
the got user madam management so that
isn't so important in the in the master
here but when it comes on to the web
application they're going to add more
things and they may want to run another
web a web app to take the load and so
they can move things around and that is
the end of what I'm going to talk about
which gives you some time for talking
asking some questions and just to say
that I'm in the middle of redoing the
the application and
[Music]
and write some new articles and you they
should be out in the next three or four
weeks depending on what other what other
things come up and I hope that will be
useful to you so have you got any
questions sir yeah
so the question was I said I use we use
all to 0 and we use so that is a company
that will provide the the authentication
for you and what we did is we just call
it that had was there there then that
email and a user ID and that's all we
used we didn't use any of the other
parts in it or Co works like asp.net
core in that if you use add things you
if they fix when you log in and that's
what we didn't we wanted to get round
doing that so we just used the user ID
any other questions
if I remember correctly I believe the
query filter does not work for
navigation properties so it's not an
issue you risk going like backwards in
in navigation properties and actually
reach properties that you should not
have access to that way yes so and this
comes down to a DDD thing called routing
at aggregate so you always put your you
put the query filter on the top of your
root class and you have to design it so
that if there are things hanging off it
that you only access them by that right
you can of course if if you do includes
that's fine but if you then want to look
at it you'd have to put a query filter
on if you wanted to directly access
those so yes you are relying on this
using a domain driven dip driven design
to to make that work and that's a that's
a good point actually
yes so what you're saying is if you're
at the top of the hierarchy and you and
where you went include including blue
include you could I'm talking about
going upwards from like you have a user
and it has a navigation properties to
the company that it belongs to then you
go up in the hierarchy and then you have
a navigation property going to a list of
users so you could actually that user
could you could risk going upwards in
the hiker and then get access to all
users you could yet you could what I do
is I have the users the control of the
users in a separate dbcontext so I've
got it's kind of like well I'm it's not
a ban Lee context but it's I've got a DP
context that deals with users and I got
a DB context which deals with companies
and so there and there is a there is a
it gets complicated but you've got a
link in here but you can't go any
further and in the company you can't get
to the users okay so yeah you're right
you the you've got to think that there's
no two little things like I really like
using a grid for a user ID because you
might have to pass that to the front end
and it's a bit more if you had in the
user with a primary key one is likely to
be a very powerful user and you'd go
after it so by using grids anonymize is
it a bit more so
you have a angular front-end yeah and
usually you want to only show what
actually the actual user is allowed to
yes this is also the cookie yeah so good
question
and I will be doing that in the the
article I'm writing in my I didn't put
it in here sorry so what happens is when
you log in you can it you can get you
can get the good you can ask for the
permissions and you get them as strings
because for the angular it's better I
think and that's what they did in the
system and if you want we didn't do it
for the client but if you want to do if
you want to catch that you would have a
change if there was this where you
updated the permissions you'd have to in
the angular you'd have to be get the
tick and see that it's changed or get
something that's saying that you should
ask for it again but it's all doable and
I'll have that in the article but you're
quite right you do need them and we we
passed them on login to the angular and
then it safe that
yes so basically we should not trust the
client right so if the client says okay
we need somehow to validate because you
are storing the permissions inside the
cookie yeah we need to make sure that
they didn't get outed yes so asp.net is
good at doing that so you most likely
will want to ask asp.net for the data
because it's active it to ensure that's
right and I do understand that for most
you know single payer apps you use
tokens and there was a whole discussion
around that and I'm not saying you can't
use tokens you can do that
I just in in this case we didn't use it
so how would you solve it with the graph
QL where you have like only one endpoint
whoa don't know who else doesn't graph
ul then go and talk talk to the web to
the api's underneath I'm not
it's querying entity framework directly
okay you would lose some of the
permission the front I'm but because the
user can basically make the wrong
queries yes for whatever they want and
you can't simply say that they're
allowed to you do this simple thing like
get products because they may have ten
different properties yeah and the
manager is supposed to be allowed to
query for all of those per staff only
four of those etc so um I've described
how I solved that problem you're gonna
have to describe how you
solve that with Groff correct I mean
this is what it's about isn't it there's
we're all finding ways to to do this so
I was hoping you would say that's coming
in version two no I'm sorry I don't
don't have that so I think we're nearly
at the end here and yeah one more
question anybody sir since you have this
owner of the data how do you handle
people leaving the company how do you
handle people leaving the company so
changing of owners and all that stuff so
[Music]
so if you so you're saying someone
leaves the company so you would just
delete the there's a something in there
that links the user to to somewhere in
the company right you if he wasn't
anywhere you could delete him but if he
leaves the company and it and this
happens often then you you remove the
link to that company right defaults
filter data can't be accessed by anybody
anymore because that person left right
so is that like you got like stale data
in your database owned by somebody who
is not there anymore
oh that in in the case of the personal
staff yes that would happen in the case
of the hierarchy the the keys are based
off the company yeah so if the company
stops then think so it's not it's not
the user ID anymore that's why I show
you the hierarchy so that is using the
this key based on the company well thank
you for your time and I hope your rest
enjoy the rest of the show and do come
and talk to me if you've got anything
else
thank you